there is some startling news from the
centers for disease control this morning
the agency says as many as
215 000 more people than usual
died in the u.s during the first seven
months of the year it suggests the
number of lives lost to the coronavirus
is significantly higher than the
official toll
a review of the data by the ap and the
marshall project
finds that half of the people who died
were people of color
it comes as the u.s death toll from
covid 19 exceeds 175
thousand the pandemic is forcing schools
to adjust
and readjust their plans to reopen for
the fall semester
michael george is in brooklyn new york
this morning michael good morning
dana good morning schools just reopened
but already we're seeing outbreaks at
multiple campuses across the country
now a lot of parents teachers and
students are anxious about a return to
the classroom
moving into college may quickly become
moving out
thanks to unsanctioned gatherings by
students many putting
fun over safety
crowd scenes posted on social media
frustrated health professionals
and fellow students i hoped that as
college students we could have been
responsible enough to maybe keep this
from happening
17 students were suspended at st olaf's
college in minnesota for partying off
campus
president david anderson wrote students
and parents this is the kind of reckless
behavior that will put an
end to our in-person semester and it
must stop
eight students have tested positive 50
are quarantined
syracuse university suspended 23
students
for crowding into the campus quad this
week at notre dame in indiana
336 confirmed covet cases were reported
leading to a plea in the student
newspaper don't make us write obituaries
but the debate over safety isn't limited
to universities
before takeoff jet blue passengers in
orlando florida had their own
bumpy ride as a flight attendant told
the mother of a two-year-old to put a
mask on the child
though she and her six children did not
continue on to newark
others who flew were delayed 53 minutes
jetblue said its policy is for
passengers over the age of two to wear
masks in accordance with cdc air travel
guidelines
and masks hard to spot at this alabama
high school football game
are required we're telling the people if
there's an outbreak there won't be high
school football
all this as the cdc warns americans need
to get their flu shots
this year more than ever
schools here in new york are set to
reopen in three weeks even as the
teachers union is raising the red flags
over safety concerns
they say if their concerns are not
addressed they'll go to court
or even strike jeff michael thank you
very much